- Les rapides de Lachine.
Un secteur prisé par de nombreux
navigateurs et amateurs
de sport nautique.
Mais ce qu'ils ne savent
peut-être pas, c'est que
s'ils tombent en panne
ou partent à la dérive,
les pompiers de Montréal
ont l'ordre de ne pas aller
les sauver s'ils dépassent
un certain point.
BENOIT MARRTEL, ex-chef respo du
secteur nautique SIM
- En théorie, on ne pourrait pas
aller secourir quelqu'un qui est
juste ici, de l'autre côté,
à quelques mètres.
- Depuis le décès du pompier
Pierre Lacroix, Benoit Martel
veut dénoncer le problème
de ce que le Service de sécurité
incendie de Montréal, le SIM,
appelle exclusion.
Il craint que l'équipage qui
accompagnait le pompier Lacroix
soit blâmé pour sa mort parce
que leur embarcation a franchi
cette zone pour tenter de sauver
la vie de plaisanciers.
- La lig- La lig- La ligne est ?
- Est quelque part ici.
Est-ce qu'on est capable de la
voir la ligne? Bien... non.
- La zone d'exclusion,
selon ce que nous avons
découvert en retrouvant
un rapport d'enquête interne
du SIM, couvre le secteur
le plus dangereux des rapides
de Lachine. Elle a été créée
par le SIM, sans tambour ni
trompette, à la suite
d'un autre chavirement en 2010.
Pour les plaisanciers, seule
cette affiche, en plein milieu
du fleuve, avertit du danger.
Mais rieMais rieMais rieMais ris
pompiers n'iront pas vous sauver
dans les rapides et qu'il n'y a
que la garde côtière qui peut
s'y rendre
- Les bateaux de la Garde
côtière, ils sont où?
Aucune idée. On ne sait pas.
Est-ce qu'on peut prendre pour
acquis que parfois ils sont là,
des fois ils ne le sont pas?
- Il se demande surtout pourquoi
l'administration Plante
encourage les citoyens
à profiter du fleuve
dans les circonstances.
- C'est soit qu'on améliore
le service à la population
de ce côté-là, ou bien il y a
des gens qui doivent être
avisés, de dire : "N'allez pas
là, parce qu'il n'y a pas
personne qui va aller
vous chercher.
- Selon nos informations,
la CNESST, qui doit présenter
jeudi les conclusions de son
enquête sur le chavirement
d'octobre dernier,era
de maintenir en place la zone
d'exclusion dans les rapides
de Lachine.
Ici Julie Dufresne, Radio-Cana.